imagine that you are an opera in cs go
and you just want to practice your
flicks counter-strike can already be
pretty dark and gloomy so imagine doing
the same thing while colorblind your
opponents kind of blend into the
background and there's a good chance you
just
might not see them well enough to react
in time well over the past decade those
dealing with color blindness
have actually found ways to bolster
their visibility in game whether it's
through the control panel of their
graphics card or settings built into the
game itself players have found ways to
unlock their true potential but in their
quest to unearth the best adjustments
vis-a-vis visibility esports competitors
have stumbled upon certain tweaks that
can help in nearly everybody but how
exactly did these colorblind settings
become pro settings and
should we all really be using them
alright so over the years gaming has
been pretty tough if you're colorblind
which for those who don't know refers to
those whose photoreceptors are either
partially or fully incapable of sensing
certain chromatic colors according to
the colorblind awareness organization 1
in 12 men and 1 in 200 women experience
some form of color blindness or color
deficiency see in spite of what all
these rogan worshipping rubes would have
you believe
men are the inferior sex and as
animation becomes more and more
realistic some people now face the same
challenges in-game that they do outside
of the server i mean it was in
elementary school i
figured out
i thought i was just like slow at
learning at colors and my mom was like
maybe you're colored blind so she like
brought me in to take a test called my
test with i don't know a doctor or
something and they're like yep
you're colorblind
now look let's take a quick step back
before you get too carried away eyes are
complicated and while i may not be an
ophthalmologist come on you thought
dimitri was going to explain the
specifics on this one your eyes
performed some critical tasks while
you're gaming that happen mostly
automatically things like spotting and
tracking targets and also grabbing other
pieces of information as quickly as
possible to help you make decisions
they're the all-important second half of
the hand-eye coordination duo so if your
eyes don't spot the target your mouse
isn't going to get there either color
vision to oversimplify relies on
different photoreceptors in your eyes
that can receive different wavelengths
of light or colors and pass that
information on to your brain when it
comes to colorblind gamers there can be
some major problems spotting and
tracking targets when the colors of the
thing they're tracking and the
environment around it match with those
weak or malfunctioning photoreceptors in
their eyes now dimitri i know you've got
plenty more to break down talking about
pros and settings and all that but hey
now you've got a new excuse when you
totally whiff that up shot in your face
it match just blame it on the colors
buddy hey
you shouldn't joke about whiffing since
okay it is a serious disease that
affects
literally dozens of scrubs daily don't
believe me just ask flom whose acute
incurable affliction resulted in him
becoming the official spokesperson of
the yet to be established american
whiffington's association call 1-800 you
suck and donate today
sometimes
all it takes to make a difference
is five gifted anyway cloud9's former ad
carry sneaky has been playing league of
legends since it first came out and in
2017 he told blitz that like many other
players he experienced his fair share of
color related issues i know tom kench
right when he came out it was pretty
massive problem um
i think they
had an immediate fix right before he
played you know he was grey health it
was
i don't know what the color was but it
just looked like his full health 24 7.
so like he could literally be one hp and
it's like uh is this gonna die sometime
now for colorblind players the early
days of league of legends
were pretty [ __ ] rough red green
colorblind players could barely even
tell the difference between their
opponent's creeps and their own they're
they're called minions
what
why do league players call last hit cs
then
god it's like this game wants to piss me
off riot's solution was a
one-size-fits-all colorblind mode which
combats both due to rinopia and
protonopia those suffering from
deuteronopia have trouble seeing green
cone pigments while those with
protonopia struggle with red cone
pigments this mode turns most of the red
and green in the game into blue and
yellow allowing players to differentiate
between all of the abilities more easily
but what riot didn't expect
was for non-colorblind players to start
adopting the same settings if you watch
a lot of pro players streams then you
might have noticed that some of their hp
bars are yellow rather than green this
is because they use a setting called
colorblind mode which was originally
meant for people who have trouble seeing
specific colors or who can't see colors
at all now by turning this on the
abilities will look much more
distinguishable and they'll actually be
easier to see you see these colorblind
changes also offered a slight
competitive advantage to visibility at a
high level
so all players started adopting them
since implementing colorblind mode back
in 2012 pretty much everyone who
actually cares about the game has turned
on the setting competitive players in
particular because even if you aren't
colorblind sometimes it can be hard to
tell what health bar belongs to what
champion especially in a hectic team
fight but mobas aren't the only genre of
game in which players have been
innovating new ways to improve
visibility
and i sure as [ __ ] didn't come here to
talk about league of legends all day so
let's get to the good stuff fps games
where even before colorblind modes
existed players were using something
called digital vibrance to really make
the colors in their game pop you might
not know this but tens the former nacs
prodigy
also had to find a way to overcome his
color blindness before becoming a world
champion in the laurent i noticed i was
colorblind i don't remember what grade
it was it was either like kindergarten
or grade one but
uh it was like a
it was like a six
slideshow thing where you have to draw
like a comic strip and it's like a scene
that changes so i drew like
i think i drew like a spider on a spider
web like crawling up a web
and then
for half of the half of the um the sun
i i drew yellow and then for the other
half of the suns i drew green
and then um i think the teacher talked
to my mom and then i went to like the
eye
uh like doctor
and i did like the numbers test on me i
couldn't see anything now tenza's
colorblindness never stopped him from
destroying everyone in fpl back in the
day but when valve added new player
models to the game in november of 2019
he had a bit of a rough go that's the
thing that kind of screwed me over the
most because
everything blends into me like i'm
really really bad with shades
so
i i couldn't see like anything like oh
dude you you're playing like a a bonus
game like when you're playing
counter-strike with player models
because people can just blend into the
environment like those dudes like
sitting like crouching down and they'll
blend into like a shrub and i can't see
it but as i'm sure many of you are aware
finding creative ways to improve your
visibility in game
has a long history in counter-strike
counter-strike has never been a bright
and colorful game but once people
decided to alter their video settings by
cranking their digital vibrance up all
the way some players discovered that the
extra contrast and saturation actually
made it easier to see enemies i have my
digital vibrance set to 100 a lot of
pros use it
at 100 so
in my opinion the game just looks better
i mean honestly you don't want to play
with a great game really anything at
least higher than 60 in my opinion is
pretty good for your eyes the reason for
this is that vibrance isn't just
saturation it doesn't brighten all
colors only the muted ones
this means that on certain maps like
mirage or inferno it yellows your
surroundings without touching the ct's
dark sas player models making them even
easier to see personally i have my
digital vibrance set to 80 sometimes 85
since i find anything 90 or above to
just be way too much that said even
those who start below the max
tend to make their way there eventually
right digital beverages
obviously a huge dick move but like i
don't know why i picked 75 but
i decided not to max it out
so after watching competitors muck
around with colorblind modes and digital
vibrance to the point that they became
synonymous with certain esports riot
decided to integrate a series of first
party options into valorant when the
beta released in april of last year
what's key here is that riot built
valorant with esports in mind so in
addition to being an obvious
accessibility feature things like
colorblind modes player outlines
and the general brightness of the game
made valorant an aimer's paradise so
when cs competitors started jumping ship
to the new game they already had
solutions to all their color issues
not that they needed them again say what
you will about valorant it's super easy
to see things riot nailed visibility to
the point that counter-strike started
copying it each of valorent's colorblind
modes combats a different color
deficiency but the important thing to
note is that the outlines created by
these modes
are just easier to see for everyone i
definitely think the yellow outline
helps me a lot more than like the red
the red didn't stand out to me at all
and i noticed that when i was playing
the beta
uh i just sucked when i i couldn't see
the red that well so i switched to
yellow and everything changed whether
you're colorblind or not seeing your
enemy in a purple or bright yellow
outline helps them stand out way more
against the game's already colorful
environments and if you tune in to watch
just about any top valorent pro or
streamer you'll notice that they're
using some combination of digital
vibrance and colorblind settings it's no
mystery that these are now the
agreed-upon standard pro settings in
ballard even at the game's first
international iceland thingy we watched
players from around the globe compete
with ridiculously oversaturated video
settings now although certain game
developers do offer colorblind modes to
aid those who suffer from color
blindness or color deficiencies the
fight isn't over competitive titles like
rainbow six siege still don't have any
colorblind options in spite of the fact
that fans have been begging for them for
years i swear dude if ubisoft would just
add some form of valorant-esque player
outline to siege i would never complain
about anything ever
again
okay i mean that's not true but i'd be
very very happy colorblind mode
i mean june as my old teammate was
colorblind he literally couldn't see
claymores and the funny thing is i have
another example for you guys jonas runs
up he he he doesn't see the claymore
like he actually doesn't see the
claymore and he doesn't kill it what
happens
is that fabian wants to help eunice
fabian died to the claymore
because jonas didn't call it out
and fabian asked jonas eunice did you
realize there was a claim on the
mainstream no i'm colorblind
riot seems to be the most accommodating
of the major esports developers but
there are still organizations out there
like can i play that who are willing to
speak on your behalf to ensure that
everyone gets to play the games they
love their accessibility reference
guides are available for game dev so
they can better understand the
challenges that some gamers face each
and every day some of their suggestions
include using sound shapes and
animations to display information rather
than different colors and games like
valerian are a prime example of
developers finally listening to this
feedback but whether you're colorblind
or not this is a fight that you should
be invested in because there's no
denying that thanks to the laborers of
the few
we've been blessed with some settings
that make everything a little bit
clearer for
well
everyone
anyway cloud nine's former ad carrie
i'm sorry arms of an angel started
playing
right as soon as i finished it and i
lost it
oh [ __ ] i'll just take my freshly
squeezed squeezed orange juice and i'll
be in my trailer
that's where you'll find me